[Music]
welcome to ibm rpa studio a
full-featured cloud-based on-prem or
software-as-a-service environment where
you can build automated process spots
that scale making your work and your
business faster safer more productive
and cost effective not a developer not a
problem build run test and publish low
code bot scripts that streamline
workflows by taking care of swivel chair
interactions and tackling repetitive
manual tasks whatever your skill set the
ibm rpa studio gives you the tools to
grow your productivity without previous
programming language experience unlock
the command toolbox to click and execute
hundreds of built-in database script and
wizard-based commands plus ai functions
email connectors and more or drag and
drop automation steps in a graphic low
code interface easily assemble tailored
repeatable concurrent bots for the
platforms you know like sap excel
outlook and more
debug solve breakpoints evaluate
variables and attach steps to runtime
create and apply existing machine
learning models train your bots with ai
and scroll back through a recording of
the steps you've made when it's time to
fine-tune something you've already done
ready to create a paperless back office
need to deliver smarter self-service
agents to customers the ibm rpa studio
is where you can design automation
scripts that get manual tasks repetitive
functions and swivel chair interactions
out of your way you can build a better
workday today
[Music]
you